Good afternoon.
Welcome. I'm very pleased to
introduce here this new session, a special session,
thanks to the joint collaboration of the American Association for Cancer Research
and the Japanese Cancer Association.
It's a long tradition that my co-chair, Dr.
Takashi Kono, will describe more in details in his closing
remarks.
We are talking today about lung cancer in never smokers.
That is considered now almost an epidemic.
Although cancer registry don't have smoking information
and so do not allow to really estimate the
incidence of these type of tumors, the decreasing of
the prevalence of tobacco smoking brought to the surface a large
number of these lung cancer in never smokers that can go up to a
quarter of all lung cancer cases, and this is particularly
evident in East Asians and in females.
There are also relatively high mortality rate.
One of our panels here in the discussion, Dr.
Jacqueline Lopickaro, estimated that mortality
rate is actually the fifth cause of cancer
death worldwide.
The dominant histology we know is adenocarcinoma.
We know that there are some distinct molecular features in
comparison to lung cancer in smokers.
And we have some important but still limited knowledge of the
important risk factors associated with lung cancer in never smokers,
and this actually limits the possibility to
identify better strategy for prevention
and identifying subjects that would benefit from
screening. We hope to be able to tackle at
least some of these questions in this session.
We will have four talks.
The first from Dr. Takashi Kono from the National Cancer Center
in Japan, that will discuss about these lung
adenocarcinoma in never smokers and
smokers in Asia.
Then we will have Jacqueline Lopickaro from Dana-Farber that will
discuss about the germline susceptibility to lung cancer in never
smokers,
will be followed by Sehong Ki from Samsung Medical Center in the
Republic of Korea, that will address all the
differences of the clinical treatment by smoking status.
And I will close with reporting some findings from
the Sherlock study and proposing a novel framework
to understand this disease.
One dominant factors across all of our talks is that we
will report from large scale studies.
It is very evident that we need large numbers
in order to tackle the interplay between inherited
susceptibility and somatic mutations, genetic ancestry,
and early age at onset. The comparisons with lung
cancer that occur in subject who smoke.
We want also to be able to integrate medical records,
multi-omics, animal models that could potentially
inform novel treatment and improve clinical
outcomes. And then there are many open questions, and we
will discuss how to tackle some of these questions.
And now, without any further ado, I'm very
happy to introduce Dr. Takashi Kono
for his talk on lung adenocarcinoma, specifically
from East Asia.
Thank you very much, Teresa. And good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Takashi Kono of National Cancer Center, Japan, and I'm
also the Vice President of Japanese Cancer Association.
So as a representative of Japanese Cancer Association,
I really appreciate your joining this session.
And this year's theme is lung cancer in never smokers.
And four speakers will talk about from the many
aspect. And I will talk about the genetics and the environmental
risk factors, referring to lung adenocarcinoma
risk.
And
this is my COI. And in fact, I'm a
director of JCGAT, Center for Cancer Genomics
and Advanced Therapeutics.
This is a national
data center for cancer genomic
medicine in Japan.
Japan has a national health insurance system, so
everybody can receive the same diagnosis and also same
therapy. And Japanese government have started
cancer genomic medicine in 2019,
and now we have six
approved gene panel test. And
these gene panel test datas are aggregated into
JCGAT national database. And also,
300 hospitals now can do the gene panel
test, and they submit clinical information.
So, the JCGAT is like a
very national initiative data center of Japan.
And up to the present, we have now aggregated
130,000 patient records,
and
the cancer types are shown here. And
And the most frequent cancer types are pancreatic cancer.
And this is because now gene panel
tests have been approved for the patient who have or who
will finish standard therapy, including
molecular-targeted therapy. So the malignant tumor patient
tend to receive gene panel test to find the next
step therapy, including off-label use
and also enrollment into clinical trials.
And today's theme, lung cancer, is also included here,
and over
7,000 cases have been aggregated.
And
we seek at collect smoking habit data
as one of the important clinical information.
And this is a summary of smoker and never
smoker fractions across tumor types.
And we are talking about advanced cancer patient who
should be treated by chemotherapy or molecular-targeted
therapy. And about 55% of
all the patient are never smokers.
Of course, these fractions differ according to
tumor types. And for example, lung cancer is one of the
cancer type containing many smoking
patient. But anyway, even in the advanced
stage, 30% of the lung cancer patients are
never smokers. And this is a fraction of
cancer cases according to the smoking dosage.
We are collecting the smoking dosage data
also. And now we can see
that as smoking dosage
increased, then the fraction of lung cancer also
increase. That mean that anyway the lung cancer is
tightly
linked to the smoking, so it's like a
smoking-related disease, you know.
And how about prognosis? We are also
obtaining the prognosis data. And
as a total, never smokers shows
better prognosis when we compare with smokers.
And when we see lung cancer data, and then lung cancer
and also head and neck cancer shows a much better
prognosis
in never smokers when we compare with smoker data.
So that means that smoking will affect of
course the development of cancer, but also it
really have much influence on the prognosis of the
patient.
And one of the reason why is the
differential alteration of cancer
oncogenes.
For example, we see the TMB data
here. And then
we know that several types of cancers are linked
to smoking as for their risk. But
anyway, difference in TMB is
most
evident in lung cancer.
TMB high patients
very much have very big fractions in
smokers in lung cancer. And this difference is most
prominent among
all tumor types.
And
the other very significant thing
is, anyway, the alteration of
gene mutation. And red circle show the
more frequent mutation in never smokers.
When we see the pan-cancer manner,
this circle is most evident. This is EGFR
mutations. I think audience
here know that EGFR is a very frequent mutations
in never smoking lung cancer. But anyway, when we see the
pan-cancer manner, EGFR mutation is
a very, very specific one.
And of course,
very good molecular-targeted therapy have been used
and implemented in daily oncology, so that
prognosis of the patient might be better than
smokers. Of course, the tumor character itself are also different
according to the smoking status.
So,
we can consider that there are two distinct pathway of
lung adenocarcinoma development driven by oncogene
mutations. One is a never smoker types, EGFR
mutations or other driver gene alteration occurs and
develop lung cancer. And the other type is a smoker type.
It is rich in KRAS mutation or lacking
known oncogene alterations. And this is
based on the data. For example, this is the data of TCGA
US patient. And then never smoker contains a lot of
EGFR mutation-positive patient.
And in smoker,
we can see many KRAS mutation and also driver
oncogene negative patient. So it is very clear that there are
two distinct
pathway for the development of lung cancer.
But this situation is a little bit different
in Asians. For example, this is a Japanese
NCC, National Cancer Center biobank data.
Of course, EGFR mutation is higher in
smokers, but even in the smokers, there are so
many EGFR positive patientSo, and
of course, our pan-negative patients are present, but so the tendency
is very, very similar. But anyway, the
actual situation is a little bit different according to the
ethnicity. So I think
we have to think that some ethnical factors
will affect the development of lung
adenocarcinoma according to smoking status.
So to address this issue, we are doing whole
genome sequencing analysis of lung adenocarcinoma of
smokers and never smokers. And that this is a
comparison of gene mutations between
EGFR positive lung cancer and negative,
like a pan-negative lung cancer. In never smoker,
both populations shows very low TMB values.
But
when we see the smokers, then we can see that the
EGFR positive patient show significantly
less
mutational burden when compared with pan cancer
patient. And when we see the mutational
signature focusing on SBS4, this is
mutational signature tightly linked to smoking.
And then again, the EGFR positive smoking patient
shows less SBS4 mutation. That means
significant portion of EGFR positive lung
cancer develop independent of smoking,
mainly in Asian.
And this is also a
summary showing our patient. For example,
in EGFR positive patient, most were never smoker,
but smoking patient showed
approximately the half of patient lack any
SBS4 mutation, even they are smokers.
So,
as Dr. Huang or Dr. Ju of KAIST have already
said that
EGFR positive lung cancer contains molecular
never smoking cases, even if they are actually,
as a human, they are smokers.
And when we see the pan-negative patient, most of the
smoker's patient contains SBS4
mutations. So this is a really
smoking-driven tumors. So
EGFR positive lung adenocarcinoma is something
specific,
like a developmental style.
And first, I searched for what are the risk
factor for EGFR positive lung cancer.
So first, we compare the
mutation pattern between the...
By using a lung adenocarcinoma cohort of never smoking
female. But they had
passive smoking or without passive smoking.
This is based on the questionnaire when they were
young, in teens and also in their 30s.
And then we compare the mutational status.
Then the EGFR mutation frequency are very
similar between these two populations, and
very high EGFR mutations.
And
when we see the tumor mutational burden, then the slightly
passive smoking increase the mutational
rate. But they are mostly APOBEC-related
mutagenesis. So passive smoking, of course, is a risk
factor for lung cancer development, but it is
completely different from the active smoking.
And also,
it never
affect the
incidence of EGFR mutation. And so we call
that passive smoking promote tumor
genesis after acquiring EGFR mutation.
And next,
recently, Dr. Swanton's group have already published that
air pollutions, such as PM2.5 levels,
are very tightly correlated with EGFR positive
lung cancer incidence. This is a cohort study of
England, South Korea, and Taiwan.
So
this might be a least environmental risk factor.
But again, they say that these air pollution
does not cause EGFR mutation directly, but
it promote
tumor genesis and progression through inflammation.
So
next, for the risk factors. So
we have been long analyzing the effect of
germline polymorphisms on the risk of lung adenocarcinoma
development. This is a collaborative study of
FLCCA, Female Lung Cancer Consortium in
Asia, led by Dr. Nat Rossman and Chin Lan of
NCI. And we did a very large JIVA
study and stratified the risk
conferred by genetic polymorphism as a polygenic
risk score. And then we showed that in
never smokers, the effect of genetic polymorphism is
greater than the smokers. So
in never smoking patient, germline
difference, germline variations have had some
effect on the development of their
tumors. And we also
didComplementary
comparative GWAS studies on EGFR
positive and negative lung cancer.
And this is also a collaborative study of seven
regions and nations in Asia. And then
we have shown that germline effect is much
higher in EGFR positive lung adenocarcinoma
when compared with EGFR negative lung cancer.
So we suppose that some genetic
factors influence the development of EGFR positive
lung cancer.
So we are now searching for the main germline
factors influencing the risk of EGFR
positive lung cancer. And then after
doing some GWAS, and then this is a GWAS of Japanese
population and HLA class II variations, and
also third polymorphisms confer
stronger risk on the development of
EGFR positive lung adenocarcinoma.
And TERT SNPs confer the longer
telomere length in leukocytes. So this
functional SNP will
cause some
cell survival or accumulation of genetic alteration
in lung cells. But anyway, the
exact
role of these polymorphisms on their risk
are largely unknown.
So we are now doing our next study.
Some majority of lung
adenocarcinoma positive for EGFR developed through
a multi-step carcinogenesis, starting from
normal lung cells, going through adenocarcinoma in
situ, and then minimally invasive adenocarcinoma,
MIA, and go to invasive adenocarcinoma.
And we did NGS analysis using these
samples. This is a tight collaboration of Dr.
Noguchi, who proposed first of the
multi-step lung adenocarcinogenesis.
And we analyzed
his samples and showed that EGFR mutations are very,
very frequent in the first stage, first step
of lung adenocarcinogenesis. That means adenocarcinoma in
situ. And the mutation is maintained through the
development and progression. And this is very in contrast
to the TP53 or other tumor suppressor gene
mutations. They occur in the later
stage
in the
development steps of lung adenocarcinoma.
And we know that these adenocarcinoma in situ
are usually diagnosed as
GGO on CT screening. This is
a GGO, ground-glass opacity. So
almost all the cases are not subjected to the surgery,
and they continue to be observed for the
growth of the GGO. And then we did
association analysis of the lung adenocarcinoma
risk associated SNPs with the risk
for GGO carrying risk. And among
the 10,000 examinees of National Cancer Screening Center,
we
extracted 500 examinees who
had
more than five millimeter GGO, and it was validated by
thin layer CT screening again.
So they were
defined as a case. And we picked up
control cases, 1,000 examinees. They
lost GGO, or they did not
have any nodules in first
CT screening. And then this is the result.
X-axis show the risk for lung
adenocarcinoma. This is
Y-axis, show the lung adenocarcinoma risk, and
X-axis show the GGO carrying risk.
Then TERT polymorphism showed both risk for
lung adenocarcinoma and for carrying
GGO. So this SNP might be involved in
the genesis of very early stage lung
tumor. And in contrast, SNPs in HLA did
not show any association for the risk of carrying GGO.
So first we supposed that TERT SNPs
affect the risk in the first development of very
early stage, very early step lung tumor.
And what happened in this stage? And then we did
some
special transcriptome analysis.
For example, this is a Noguchi type B, and this is
like an initial stage of lung tumor development,
and we could find several lesion
interacting tumor cell with immune cells.
But it is very, very restricted.
When we move on to the, for example, Noguchi type
C, this is MIA, minimally invasive adenocarcinoma,
then we can see the lesion, or possibly
malignant and invasive lesion based on the expression pattern
and also cell proliferation patterns.
And in this area, we could see many
markers in immune engagement and
tumor adaptationSo,
this is an example of B-cell markers, and also B-cell
attracting pro-inflammatory
chemokines
expressed in this area. And we could also see a
tertiary lymphoid structure here.
So anyway, this
stage starts active immune cell and tumor
cell interactions. So we think that,
we suppose that HLA class II, this is really a major
player in immune interaction.
So HLA class II variation may affect the risk
here.
And we are now on the way to define the
really responsive HLA alleles. This is one of the
examples,
HLA DPB1 0301
confers a more stronger risk for EGFR positive
lung adenocarcinoma risk. And we have several signals.
So, we will see the interaction and expression
pattern on those, so immune cell distribution according
to the carrying
HLA risk allele, and also no risk
alleles.
So,
this is my take-home message. And lung cancer is
anyway the most smoking-influenced cancer,
and it is
in a view of genomics and prognosis.
And EGFR positive lung cancer develops both in smokers and
never smokers. But a measure of the patient,
small tumors developed mostly independent of
smoking.
And germline variants affect lung cancer risk
stronger in never smokers and EGFR positive cases.
And third variants affect early tumor initiation, and the
HLA variant may affect the progression and invasion risk.
And this is a collaboration, and this is my
acknowledgement of collaborators.
This is many people in National Cancer Center, and also a
tight collaboration with distinguished pathologist, Dr.
Masaike Noguchi and Dr. Daisuke Matsubara.
And also this is a collaboration of CCAG and also FLCCA.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Takashi. We have just a couple of minutes for
questions.
So over here.
Yes.
Over here. Hi. Nice talk. I have two quick questions.
The first one is, are these polymorphisms also seen in North
American populations?
Yes.
Do they correlate with risk in North Amer-- I know they're seen, but do they
correlate with risk in North American populations?
Yes. So for example, if we see the TART polymorphism,
the frequency of the polymorphism is higher in Asian
population. But for example, HPV DPB1, this
is the same frequency between the
Caucasian and Asians. So,
these polymorphisms do not
solve the problem of ethnicity dependency.
Okay. My second question is, do you have a comment on gas stoves
and their risk for lung cancer?
I will.
You will.
Thank you so much.
The question I had was that you mentioned that EGFR mutations are
high. Are they in both smokers and non-smokers?
Are the number of EGFR mutations more in smokers in
comparison to non-smokers? Because it looked like they were more, so
I'm just confused about that.
Of course, EGFR mutation
is less frequent in smokers when we compare with
never smokers. But a significant portion of
EGFR positive lung cancer in smokers developed independent
of SBS4 mutational signature,
SBS4 mutational accumulation. So, we want to say that
it is less
linked to smoking.
We go on the other side. I would say just another one.
Maybe afterwards we can have more time. But yeah.
Great talk. Tomozan from NCI. So I wondering
is there any
specific mutation difference between the EGFR
in smokers and the EGFR in never smokers, for
example, the hotspots?
Yes. It's a very good question, and we examined in
detail, but there are no differences.
There's no difference.
Yes. So for exam-
We did-
You know?
We did see some differences.
Oh, really?
Yeah. So that would be interesting to... Yeah. Yes.
And my second question is, you found a strong association between the HLA
loci and the EGFR positive risk, right?
Do you have any hypothesis for this association?
Why the HLA-
Yeah.
Have effect in EGFR.
So yes, it's a very good question. And there are several reports
that HLA class II is expressed not only in
immune cells but also in lung cancer cells.
And the high expression of class II
are reported to be linked with good
prognosis. So some HLA class II
molecules, some effect of immune
invasion, and also immune ejection.
Great talk. I will make it real quick.
So for your smokers versus non-smokers EGFR mutated
patients, do you see any difference in response or patterns
in response to EGFR-targeted therapy?
So,
Dr Lee will present the data. Yes.
Please look forward to his talk.
Very happy that there is a lot of coordination among all our
talks. We will address questions from different points of view.
So thank you again.
Thank you very much.
And I would like now to introduce Dr.
Jacqueline Lo Piccolo from Dana-Farber, who will tell
us about the germline susceptibility to lung cancer in never smokers.
Thank you for the opportunity to present today.
I'll be discussing germline variation in oncogene-driven young onset
and familial lung cancer with a focus on how inherited
variation contributes not only to lung cancer risk but may also
influence tumor biology in these groups with little to no smoking history.
And these are my disclosures.
So the heritability of lung cancer has been estimated at
18% with substantial contribution
from shared environment. And this degree of heritability is lower
than other cancers such as breast, prostate, ovarian, and
some skin cancers, but higher than most GI cancers.
And importantly, these estimates come mainly from smoking populations
where shared exposures predominate.
So in those without smoking history, the relative contribution of inherited risk
may be higher.
But generally speaking, having a first-degree relative with lung cancer
increases your risk of lung cancer by about twofold, and more if that
relative is diagnosed at a young age.
Historically, prior GWAS have focused mainly on smoking-related lung cancer,
which is the most common type of lung cancer, and have identified
loci that mediate smoking behavior.
And in contrast, GWAS from never smokers have
not converged in the same way on a robust set of
associations and tend to,
generally speaking, consider European and Asian
populations separately.
And although rare variant and familial studies have pointed to genes
like ATM and BRCA and EGFR, we
don't totally understand the genetic architecture of risk in
non-smoking lung cancer.
So this is a conceptual model that we have proposed where
germline variation interacts with environmental exposures and somatic
alterations to ultimately influence lung cancer development in those who have
not smoked. So starting on the left, you have germline
variation, which exists across the spectrum.
There's common variants, individually, each with small effect sizes.
Examples of this are polygenic risk scores that are comprised of
SNPs identified in GWAS. And then on the other end
of the spectrum, you have your rare and ultra-rare variants with much
larger effect sizes. And examples of this are
pathogenic germline
mutations in TP53, BRCA2, or ATM.
And this germline variation can then affect processes such
as DNA repair, carcinogen metabolism, and
inflammation. And this can be reflected then at the somatic level, where
you can have inactivation of tumor suppressors and activations of
oncogenes. And then on the right,
all of this, in part, can shape tumor biology, including
ultimately selection of drivers, presence of co-mutations,
and interaction with the microenvironment.
And then you have the actual environment, the
exposome, that can interact
at all levels with the germline and somatic genome and
ultimately influence tumor biology.
And so rather than acting in isolation, we think these things are all
interconnected. And this raises the question of how inherited
variation shapes not just risk, but the specific tumor
subtype that develops from a histologic and molecular standpoint.
So one way to approach this is to focus on populations that we think are
enriched for inherited susceptibility.
And in particular, I have focused on three groups that are comprised of mostly
non-smoking disease, the first two of which I will focus on
today. The first is patients with young onset disease, and
for these purposes, that's defined as diagnosed at 45
or younger.
The second are individuals with family histories of lung cancer or personal
histories of other cancers, including multiple cancers over a lifetime.
And then the third are tumors defined by specific drivers,
prototypically EGFR mutant lung cancer.
And importantly, these groups are not mutually exclusive, and in fact, the areas
where they overlap may be the groups that have actually the
most strong germline contributions to risk.
So to study these groups, we developed two correlative research studies that
recruit patients nationwide. The first is called the Biology of Young Lung
Cancer or Young Lung Cancer study, and this is focusing on people
diagnosed at 45 or younger. The second is called INHERIT, or
Investigating Hereditary Risk in Thoracic Cancers.
This focuses on individuals with familial risk, and we are running this in
partnership with GO2 for Lung Cancer.
And both studies are coordinated through Dana-Farber, but recruit nationally with
remote sample collection. Sequencing is performed at the Broad Institute, and
then analysis is performed by our group.
So to enable national recruitment, both studies enroll remotely through study
websites and online platforms. People can enroll from anywhere in the
US, and this allows us to reach groups that otherwise would be difficult to
capture at a single center, particularly for rare subgroups like young
onset lung cancer and familial lung cancer.
And this really enables us to build these cohorts at scale for the genomic analyses
that we want to do.
So it might be helpful to understand the types of data and samples that we
are collecting.
At the time of consent, people enroll remotely.
There's in-home phlebotomy for them to provide a research blood sample
for germline whole genome and RNA sequencing and serum
for banking.They also complete detailed exposure and medical
and family history questionnaires.
These include detailed residential histories, so kind of tracking where people have
lived over the course of their lives, and also occupational
history as well, and then access to medical
records. The optional items, there are optional items.
The first one is clinical germline multigene panel testing.
So this is run through our commercial partner, Invitae, and it's a bespoke
assay consisting of 156 genes across cancer types
made for the study. And there is pre- and post-test genetic counseling
that comes with this, and then for people who are found to have pathogenic germline
variants, there's cascade testing available for family members if they want it.
Second is access to tumor specimens, which is optional, but most people actually do
consent to this, and then serial blood collection every six to 12 months
for banking and future study.
So turning to young onset lung cancer, it's relatively rare.
It makes up about 1% to 2% of overall lung cancer.
Mostly occurs in people who have never smoked and highly enriched for targetable
alterations. Somewhere upwards of 90% will have one.
There's not any unifying exposure or genetic risk factors identified,
and in the past, it's been hard to study because there just aren't that many
patients.
So taking a deeper dive into the somatic data, we looked at the AACR
Project Genie database at over 7,000 lung adenocarcinomas,
and we saw that younger patients did indeed show enrichment for certain targetable
alterations. Most notably, ALK and ROS1
fusions. Those have asterisks next to them on the x-axis.
And then also to a lesser extent, but still, EGFR
mutations associated with younger age.
And then when you look at all fusions grouped together, all fusions
represented in this figure, you can see that there is even
stronger and more significant enrichment for younger onset
disease. And this is in contrast to KRAS mutant lung cancer, which we
found was associated with older patients, which is not surprising given that we
know it's associated with mostly smoking-related disease.
So turning back to the study, we assembled a cohort of young onset patients for
germline whole genome sequencing.
And as I mentioned, these are people 45 or younger at the time of diagnosis,
and it's non-small cell and small cell lung cancer patients.
The cohort was mainly non-small cell, but we did certainly
see some small cell lung cancer cases.
So to date, this cohort includes 620 patients with young onset lung
cancer.
It is predominantly female, adenocarcinoma histology,
stage IV disease, and never or light smoking history.
So 87% of the cohort have five pack years or less.
And then on the bottom here, this is the landscape of
somatic alterations. You can see it's mostly ALK fusions and EGFR
mutations, kind of a smattering of other known drivers, and then a
group
with unknown drivers. And then on the right, this is a map of
participation, so where people reside at the time that they enroll.
So we did have pretty representative participation across the US,
with participants from nearly every state.
So looking at some of the data from this cohort, we performed germline whole
genome sequencing at a data freeze of 251
samples. Median age of
onset was 37, and we analyzed these data
jointly with raw data from 196
never-smoking lung adenocarcinoma cases from the Sherlock Lung
Study. These were published as part of a tumor normal
whole genome study in 2021.
And we analyzed these populations alongside roughly
1,800 cancer-free controls from the TOPMed database.
So, in terms of what we analyzed, we looked at short and structural variants,
structural variants being 50 base pairs or greater in size.
And this included common variants that compose polygenic risk scores and then
rare coding variants in gene and gene set based
burden testing. And we then correlated this burden with clinicopathological
information such as survival and smoking status, as well as
somatic data. And we can see in Panel B, so we
captured a fairly wide spectrum of variation among short and
structural variants.
In Panel C, in terms of ancestry, the population was largely
European, about 85%, and these were the
samples that we used in our downstream analysis.
And then in this last panel, we calculated polygenic risk scores
study-wide based on a recent cross-ancestry
GWAS meta-analysis of over 60,000 lung cancer
cases. And what you can see here is that in both cancer
sample sets, the young onset
patients and the never-smoking patients compared to controls, the
polygenic risk scores for lung adenocarcinoma were associated with a
small amount of risk. The odds ratios were in the 1.3 range per
standard deviation increase in PRS.
And this was interesting to us, given that this PRS was derived mainly from
smoking-associated lung cancer, and it suggests that some component of inherited
risk may be shared across smoking and non-smoking disease.
So to increase power in this relatively modest sample size, we
aggregated variants at the level of biologically defined
gene sets and pathways. And so these were pathways a
priori that are known to be involved in either lung cancer biology or cancer
biology in general. And out of 146 gene sets
that we tested among young onset cases, we saw enrichment for
rare pathogenic variation across 55 of those
cancer-associated gene sets. And these are the top
hits here. These were the most significant.
And they included TP53 as a single gene.
That was the only gene set that we composed of a single gene, more for
positive control, but we were really surprised to see the degree of
enrichment among the young onset cases compared to the non-smoking cases,
and also the effect sizes were quite large.And then the other pathways
we saw enrichment were signaling pathways involved in non-small cell lung cancer,
tumor suppressor gene sets, the clinical panel from Invitae that I
mentioned earlier, and then some pediatric and adult cancer
gene sets as well. And if you look on the x-axis,
across the x-axis, we're varying how stringently
we define damaging variants. So CV is ClinVar pathogenic variants,
and then as you move to the right, there are more inclusive definitions
incorporating predicted functional impact.
Then the categories become less stringent from left to right.
So overall, this suggests that rare pathogenic germline
variation in established cancer genes contributes to risk in young onset
lung cancer.
So having seen enrichment at the level of the gene sets, we asked whether there
were specific genes driving these signals.
To do this, we performed an exome-wide rare variant association
test across roughly 19,000 genes.
And these are QQ plots that show results on the left for all lung cancers
and then non-fusion driven lung cancers, and then fusion driven lung
cancers.
And what you can see is that we see clear deviation from expectation with
TP53, again, emerging as the strongest signal among all lung
cancers. But then when we stratified by tumor subtype, so
non-fusion cancers in the middle, we saw another gene emerge, which
was SMAD6, that suppresses TGF-beta signaling.
And then in fusion driven lung cancers, a gene called IREB2,
which regulates intracellular iron homeostasis and actually lies
within a known lung cancer susceptibility locus.
So when we look to see where these variants actually were in the proteins, they do
cluster in functionally important domains, and it supports their
potential biological relevance and suggests to us that rare
germline variation contributes not only to overall risk, but to
specific pathways and tumor subtypes that develop.
So the last thing we looked at is whether structural variants, so these
are variants greater than 50 base pairs in size, also contribute to risk.
And looking first at the gene set level burden, we
see enrichment of rare loss of function structural variants
in the young onset cases. And we saw this particularly in sets
of genes that were lung expressed and loss of function
intolerant, and those are the ones that are circled with the dashed
lines. We then focused on very large structural variants,
so those greater than one megabase in size, where we did see a clear excess
in young onset cases, particularly with regard to large
deletions.
And then this enrichment we found was most pronounced in patients with
fusion driven tumors, where large rare structural
variants were significantly enriched compared to both controls, which are on the
lower left, and then fusion negative cases
on the lower right.
So we can think about these findings as a multilayered model of risk,
where you have germline variation that operates across rare coding variants,
structural variants, and polygenic risk,
alongside environmental exposures such as air pollution.
And this was something we did not look at in this study but would like to
because we think there's likely a large environmental contribution here, and
there's an interplay between genetics and environment, which is something we really
want to look at in this space, particularly around the propensity for
air pollution to cause inflammation in the lung.
And then exposure-wise, a lot of questions are remaining in terms of how much
exposure, when does it matter, and for how long.
So these are all questions we want to answer in this population with
future study.
But ultimately, all of these things can converge in the lung and influence
oncogene selection and lung cancer subtype.
So given the wide array of treatments available for somatic
genotype-directed therapy, germline genotype rarely impacts treatment in
lung cancer. But this is an example where germline
findings actually had pretty profound therapeutic implications.
So this is a patient with a pathogenic germline variant in
BRCA2 and no targetable somatic alterations
despite extensive profiling at the exome and RNA levels.
There was, however, loss of heterozygosity of BRCA2
in the tumor. And so this patient responded exceptionally well to
platinum-based chemotherapy followed by targeted therapy with a PARP inhibitor.
She was diagnosed with stage four disease over six years ago.
Still alive today, and the progression points that she had
included multiple CNS lesions and leptomeningeal spread.
But this disease was responsive to chemotherapy for almost four years,
and then a PARP inhibitor for 16 months after that.
And these included really
durable responses of several years with regard to the CNS
and leptomeningeal lesions.
So now I'll talk about familial lung cancer and the INHERIT study
for a bit.
So we're running this study in partnership with Go2Alchemy.
It's focused on families with suspected hereditary lung cancer
risk. And here we have three cohorts.
We have cohort one, which are those who carry or have relatives
who carry germline EGFR mutations, such as
EGFR T790M is the most probably
well-known. And then we have others like R776H
and some others that are listed there.
And then cohort two are people with either a personal or
family history of lung cancer who
carry or have relatives who carry pathogenic germline mutations in
non-EGFR genes, but genes that we think are involved in familial lung
cancer, such as HER2, YAP1,
TP53, and others. And then cohort
three are those with no known mutations but strong family histories of lung
cancer, and they do not necessarily need to have a history of lung
cancer
themselves.So a key goal of this
work is to define risk and develop
screening strategies for high-risk
populations. And the prototypic population to do this in are
the EGFR T790M carriers.
Because as I'll talk about in a minute, the carriers without lung cancer very
often have pre-malignant nodules, ground-glass nodules, that
actually represent adenocarcinoma spectrum lesions, and they become
malignant over time. And we see these nodules starting
in carriers as young people in their 20s.
So for cohort one, these T790M mutation carriers, we have a CT
screening arm for up to 150 participants.
So as of this month, this is study progress. For this study, it's ongoing.
We're continuing to recruit and enroll patients and families
across the United States, and these are people, as I mentioned, also are getting
germline whole genome and RNA sequencing.
So I'll talk briefly about the EGFR T790M
variant. So familial clustering of lung cancer has long
been recognized, but only a small number of high-risk germline variants have been
identified. And one of the first
to be identified was EGFR T790M, and that was reported
first in 2005 in a family with multiple cases of lung
adenocarcinoma and minimal smoking history.
Since then, there have been additional families that have been reported to have
this mutation, another germline EGFR variance.
And what's unique about T790M is that it's actually a well-known
somatic resistance mutation to earlier generation EGFR
inhibitors. And so we often or sometimes
identify this
mutation incidentally by people who are getting either blood-based or
tumor-based NGS because if somebody has a
T790M mutation prior to ever receiving any
EGFR-directed therapy, the chances that it's germline are about
50%.
So in the
T790M carriers who develop lung cancer, the tumors typically
acquire a second activating EGFR mutation in
cis with the T790M. Most commonly is the EGFR
L858R mutation, but there are G719X
mutations and some other point mutations that occur in cis with
T790M. And then together, this leads to enhanced oncogenic
signaling and eventually an invasive adenocarcinoma.
So we've enrolled a number of families on this study, but this is just two
representative families. These are pedigrees showing that
the T790M allele clearly segregates with lung cancer in affected
families.
And what you can see, the pink squares are lung cancer, the pluses and
minuses are T790M genotype, and the blue squares represent
pulmonary nodules, which I was alluding to before, these pre-malignant
spectrum lesions that many carriers have and enable screening to be really
effective in this population. And you can see that it's pretty prevalent
among the younger generation.
So this is a much more rare germline
EGFR variant, R776H, but we do have a few families.
And you can see it also can be similarly penetrant.
This one, there's a
number of people in this family obviously who have lung cancer, but also that
have nodules. So kind of suggesting a broader role for germline EGFR
mutations in general. And then in these
carriers, for example, the T790M carriers, we can observe
stepwise acquisition of somatic changes, which provides some insight into
tumor evolution in this population.
And these are lesions that came from a resection specimen from a T790M
carrier with somatic profiling of each lesion individually.
And interestingly, what we saw was that even in the pre-malignant and
smaller lesions, so the atypical adenomatous hyperplasia and
the minimally invasive adenocarcinoma,
those also had second somatic hits in
EGFR, in addition to obviously the invasive lung adenocarcinomas.
And then there were some other genes that were
co-mutated in different lesions, but we were very surprised to
see that the
second somatic EGFR mutation was a relatively early event.
So to extend these findings to the population level, we have a
collaboration ongoing with 23andMe, where we are analyzing
over 3.5 million research participants.
And this allows us to really study this variant at scale and quantify
its precise contribution to lung cancer risk at the population
level. And this data currently falls outside the scope
of this talk, but it's an interesting approach to a rare variant like this.
So towards a framework for inherited risk in non-smoking lung cancer,
we know it's a distinct biological entity.
We know it is enriched for oncogenic drivers and an inherited risk.
We think this architecture is multilayered.
As I've talked about, rare variants, structural variants, and modest polygenic
effects. We know that high penetrance alleles exist, such
as EGFR T790M, also those in TP53.
But in the case of T790M, in the
data that we've looked at, it seems to be largely independent of polygenic risk,
which is perhaps not surprising. We know that oncogene selection
and tumor evolution may be shaped in part by the germline, and
integrating germline somatic and exposure information is what is going
to enable us to really classify people from a biologic standpoint and
ultimately prioritize these people for screening, which is the ultimate
goal of all this research.
And so finally, I just wanted to highlight a few ways that we can work together.
So
we have created a lung cancer genetics clinic at Dana-Farber, where myself
and our team of genetic counselors see people that we suspect to have
inherited risk, and we welcome referrals.
Secondly, I co-direct the Young Lung Cancer program with Narjus Flores,
and this is at the Dana-Farber, and we see young lung cancer
patients focus on the clinical, psychosocial, and research needs of
this population.The studies for anybody who thinks they
have a patient or an individual who might be eligible or anybody who thinks they
themselves might be eligible, you can go to the study websites and there's an
eligibility questionnaire. Somebody from the team will get back to you.
And then lastly, if you're interested in collaborating or joining this work, I
would be very happy
to connect.
And then lastly, I would like to thank my mentors.
My primary mentors, Pasienna and Sasha Gusev.
My kind of larger network of mentors, Judy Garber, David Christiani,
Bruce Johnson, and David Barbee. And my colleagues and
collaborators, Ryan Collins and Noah Fields,
and
everybody else who's made this work possible.
I would also like to thank Alice Shaw and the session coordinators for this
opportunity to speak today.
Thank you.
Questions? Yes.
Yes. In your young cohorts, did you
see any influence of gender
or ethnicity?
Influence on the germline findings or-
Yes.
Yeah. No, we didn't
see that.
In the model you proposed, there is the impact of the environmental
exposure.
In your young cohorts, did you look at
epidemiological factors, zip codes, and
jobs, occupation? Did anything fall out?
Your focus was clearly the germline-
Yeah
... alterations, but did any of the epidemiological factors
So we do have zip code information. We did look at zip codes.
We did not see any clear associations, but I think the sample size was just
too small. In those 251 people that I showed,
and then to do kind of genetic by environment interactions, we're definitely
underpowered for that. But, I think in the larger cohort, it'll be interesting to
look at.
So it would also be interesting, sorry,
in terms of fusions and mutations as well.
There could be potentially a difference.
Certainly, yeah.
If I can, I also have a question, Jackie.
So in the young group, in the young cohort, if I understood
correctly, I think it was dominated by
TP53 germline. So I'm wondering if...
And also they were mostly advanced stage, right?
Mm-hmm.
So I just was wondering whether you have seen in
this younger cohort also the
stages through pre-malignant lesion, or is it we are talking about
the tumor that evolves very rapidly?
I think the latter mainly from what I've seen in this cohort, yeah.
Yeah. Okay, thank you.
Yeah.
Do you have any-
May I have question, Jacqueline?
I'm very interested in your great
prospective study of germline
positive lung
patient,
person.
But
how do you find
the familial
lung cancer families who are
EGFR germline positive patient? How to find?
Yeah. That's a great question. We do work with the advocacy groups in the
US, so they take this study to their EGFR
mutant lung cancer patients, and then some of them will refer their family
members.
And the rest of it is really just sometimes word of mouth, and
we end up finding a lot of relatives through one person from a family, and then we
end up getting-
I see.
Thank you very much. And may I have one more?
Yes. Also, we get referrals from genetic counselors, and we get referrals from
companies who detect these mutations.
I see.
That's right.
The other question is,
what is the role of EGFR
T790M mutation?
This is a little bit oncogenic or largely
oncogenic when in the
carrier.
Yeah.
Do you have some oncogenic role directly that EGFR
T790M mutation?
I think it partially activates the protein, and then they get the second somatic
mutation that's the full activation.
But in terms of do you think it makes it more likely that there will be another
mutation that happens in EGFR? Because I think that is one thing
that we've wondered is if having this weak activation kind of
predisposes to a second mutation happening.
I see.
I don't know if I can add another one.
But,
so you showed at the end, the collaboration with 23andMe
with over 3 million
participants. So
could you share what's the frequency of the EGFR
variants? At least in a population so large, you will get the
sense of the-
Yeah. So it was really interesting because roughly speaking, so
in the US, it was like
one 10 to the minus five about. But what we did
see was geographic clustering, in the Southeast US.
And then in those populations, specifically Caucasian people
who reside in the Southeast US, it was more on the order of one in
8,000 or something like that. So it was a pretty strong enrichment in that area of
the country due to the fact that it's a founder mutation-
Oh
... in the Southeast US. So yeah.
And they were mostly white, you said?
Yes.
Interesting.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you very much, Jacqueline.
Next speaker is Dr. Seeng-Lern Lee of Samsung
Medical Center.
He gave a very good talk in our previous
annual JCA meeting, and he was selected as
the-Presenter of this session this year.
Yes.
So Dr. Lee, could you please start your talk?
Yeah. I'm Seung Lee from Samsung Medical Center.
So I'm very great honor to present here and talk
about never smoker lung cancer. And actually, I
give my special thanks to Dr. Oshima and Dr.
Tschumper
and again, many thanks to, yeah, so Dr. Randy and Dr. Conor.
Yes. So today my topic is differential response to
anticancer treatment depending on smoking status in lung
cancer.
This is my disclosure. Actually, I'm a clinician, so
actually my presentation will be more focused on the clinical
side.
So of course, lung cancer in never smoker is
recognized as the fifth most common cancer type in the world.
And we already know that lung cancer in never smoker
pathogenetogenesis is very different from smoker related
pathogenetogenesis.
And due to the different pathogenetogenesis, actually
they have some different genomic structure, of course.
So due to the genomic structure, so actually many driver mutations
is initiated in never smoker, we already know.
So again, we already know a very harsh
microenvironment for immune checkpoint inhibitor in never smoker lung cancer
compared to smokers. It is very contrary to the early
success story of a smoker lung cancer.
So lung cancer in never smoker had different pathogenetogenesis
and different genomic structure and different immune
context compared to smoker. So what is the
different response to the therapy?
And it is a very important clinical implication for clinician and
patient.
So I will start with just a brief chemotherapy
pharmacokinetic story of smoking, and next I'm moving
to the targeted therapy. Actually, targeted therapy is the most
widely studied period. So, and third one is immune
checkpoint inhibitor response. It is actually very
rarely studied population, yet but we have a very big
large cohort of the never smoker lung cancer.
So I will present some preliminary result from our cohort data.
So first of all, I think, chemotherapy relating to the
smoking or pharmacokinetics. Actually, we already know
smoking-related material, polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbon, can induce cytochrome P450
enzyme. So this means, some
drug, erlotinib or irinotecan, have increased clearance
in the smoker and lower plasma concentration in smoker
too. So, actually NCCN guidelines list up these two
drugs for smoking and never smoker differences on the drugs.
So as you can see,
what is its clinical implication?
So actually we usually treat smoker lung cancer.
But never smoker lung cancer, actually the exposure is
erlotinib and irinotecan will be increasing.
So this means sometimes it is leading to the better efficacy,
but sometimes it's leading to the increased toxicity to never smoker
patient. So we should be very careful of the erlotinib
and irinotecan prescription for never smoker lung cancer.
So I'm moving to the targeted therapy.
It is a very long period with most
of the data.
So in never smoker, EGFR TKI is
more benefit compared to smoker. It is very
definite from the many meta-analysis.
As you can see, never smoker hazard ratio 0.3,
both smoker 0.5. So actually definitely
different and if we compare directly smoker
and never smoker, again, never smoker hazard ratio
0.7 compared with a smoker. It's a better
benefit to the EGFR TKI.
So, and it is very dose dependent population.
Of course, it is not a prospective study, it's just observation
study. Yeah, but actually those responsiveness is
confirmed in EGFR TKI in never smoker population.
And in practice, we usually EGFR
TKI and now sometimes we combine with
anti-angiogenic agent. If we put anti-agent,
what difference is the benefit never smoker and
smoker? As you can see, if
we combine with the anti-angiogenic with EGFR
TKI, the benefit is more prominent in
smoker. So actually never smoker population has
less benefit from the addition of the anti-angiogenic.
So of course, it is a very important issue in Asia population
and Japanese population. Of course,
benefit is not zero, yeah, but benefit is
more prominent in smoker.
So again, now we have another combination of EGFR
TKI. So actually we are using EGFR TKI and cyto
toxic based on the PERAL2, and we are using EGFR
TKI and EGFR bispecific as your multipotent
regimen. So as you can see, this benefit is very
similar. So actually, EGFR TKI benefit is
more prominent in never smoker, but addition of the other
agent is more prominent in the never smoker.
Actually smoker impact is more beneficial.
So interestingly, in contrary to the EGFR TKI-ARC
TKI, the effect of the never smoker is
smaller than the
EGFR TKI. As you can see, never
smoker cohort hazard ratio is 0.4 and
smoker is 0.5. Yeah, so actually less prominent
beneficial in the never smoker population of the ARC
TKI. Probably this issue is very related with the
signature issues. Actually, some papers state that
ARC population has even smoker ARC population,
they have usually very small SBS4 signature
relating smoking
exposure.
So actually, the last one, immune checkpoint inhibitor
differential response is
most important I think.
So according to the pivotal early clinical
trial, the immune checkpoint monotherapy shows less
benefit in never smoker compared to smoker.
Actually, we already know of very importantly.
So even if you will limit to just the
PD-L1 high population, this benefit is not
transferred to the never smoker population.
As you can see, never smoker population has a very low
objective response rate, progression-free survival, and finally overall
survival, compared to heavy smoker
population, even we limit to PD-L1 high.
So another issue is immune checkpoint inhibitor and cytotoxic
chemotherapy. So sometimes we are using immune
checkpoint inhibitor and the cytotoxic to improve the efficacy
of just the immune checkpoint monotherapy.
But actually, very interestingly, so it is a very
early pivotal trial. So of course, the number is
very small. So this data shows somewhat
similar or
actually paradoxically better efficacy compared to the smoker.
Yeah, but again, another following clinical
trial, 10898, showed that actually never
smoker population had less benefit to immune checkpoint inhibitor
even we combine cytotoxic and immunotherapy.
So again, Dana-Farber and MSKCC LogicBee cohort
real world data also showed that never smoker has a
very little benefit from the immune checkpoint inhibitor and
cytotoxic chemotherapy. So this means never
smoker population, of course, better immune checkpoint with
cytotoxic,
rather than monotherapy, but still very big unmet
need of immune checkpoint inhibitor and cytotoxic chemotherapy.
So it is again another meta-analysis shows a very
similar result.
So as a clinician, we have a very important clinical
implication. So immune checkpoint inhibitor monotherapy or
combination with a cytotoxic chemotherapy had less benefit in
never smoker compared to smokers.
As we know, actually, immune checkpoint inhibitor will be the very
important treatment tool for all cancer patient.
But never smoker lung cancer patient has a very little benefit from the immune
checkpoint inhibitor. But we dissect this
phenomenon very carefully as a clinician perspective.
First clinical implication is one is some
lung cancer in never smoker patient lose the opportunity of
immune checkpoint inhibitor. So actually, we have some
response to the immune checkpoint inhibitor monotherapy or combination therapy,
but sometimes clinicians or patients abandon
the treatment option of immune checkpoint inhibitor in never smoker
population. So we should be very aware of this issue
is important clinical implication one.
Another implication is actually very contrary
side. Some lung cancer in never smoker patient have
risk of unnecessary, sometimes harmful due to
hyperprogression immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy.
So as a clinician, our
mission should be through the dissection of
molecular heterogeneity, actually
identification sensitive marker for
first clinical implication part one, and resistance
biomarker for clinical implication part two.
So it is a very important mission for
clinician and clinical scientist, I think. Yes.
So of course, many including Sherlock Lung, yes,
actually, we are showing the heterogeneity within the lung cancer in
never smoker population.
So it is the last year ESCO meeting.
So also US multicenter collected
the never smoker population. So as you can see,
PD-L1 is
a little
biomarker for sensitivity, but overall survival is not
different. And again,
TMB score
is
higher than the 90 percentile. This means
a very small number of never smoker population have a benefit from
the immune checkpoint inhibitor monotherapy or combination therapy
in terms of progression-free survival and overall survival.
So again, very interestingly, use of dual
checkpoint blockade are associated with improved outcome
compared to immune checkpoint monotherapy in never
smoker lung cancer without actionable genetic
alterationsYeah. But it is
probably the best
description of the predictive biomarker for never smoker lung cancer
population.
So we have established a large
immuno-oncology clinical genomic database in
my institution.
So actually we have 5,000 patient
cohort. So actually
due to the unique characteristics in East Asian,
never smoker lung cancer had 40%.
So among the 5,000 patients,
2,000 patients are never smoker and 3,000 patients are smoker
population. And as you know, in Korean population,
very similar to the Japanese, yeah, so actually we have a very unique
genetic background. So I think it is a very good,
important
database for the comparison of the
EGFR or other never smoker genetic risk
factors. So I will show some examples of
our active preliminary data.
So it is just around 600. Of course, yes,
so definitely never smoker population.
Actually all population is the immune checkpoint
monotherapy or immune checkpoint
plus cytotoxic combination therapy.
Actually, 80% patients has immune checkpoint monotherapy and
20% immune checkpoint plus cytotoxic chemotherapy.
So in total, yes, definitely never smoker has
less benefit from the immune checkpoint monotherapy combination,
and definitely lower tumor mutation burden and
lower PD-L1 score.
So again, we
tested predictive biomarker or PD-L1 and TMB.
So as you can see, actually
TMB score is very lower compared to the smoker,
even high number of the
TMB among the never smoker. So it is
another good biomarker for prediction of
individual patient sensitive or resistant aspect.
So I will show two example of a sensitive
biomarker from our cohort. So how can we
see this cohort for the patient management?
So the first example,
from around 500 cohort, PBAP
mutation, especially loss of function mutation, it is
around 10% of the
lung cancer population and never smoker population.
Actually incidence is very similar to population.
So actually, this PBAP mutation data
is some good sensitive biomarker for the
never smoker lung cancer. And this finding also was
validated using Asia Genie cohort.
So it is a very interesting case. So this
patient EGFR mutation,
and of course never smoker and low PD-L1 score.
As I commented, sometimes we will lose or
miss the opportunity of immune checkpoint inhibitor for this
patient. So fortunately, he was treated with immune
checkpoint inhibitor monotherapy.
As you can see, his tumor response was very
good. Actually very good partial remission
category. And this response maintained more than
five years. So he is very
well, alive status now with just the
monotherapy session.
The second
sensitive marker example. So we
analyzed whole transcription data around 400.
It is just limited to adenocarcinoma.
As you know,
adenocarcinoma and squamous carcinoma is a very different
TME environment and very different genetic background.
So
we usually limit to adenocarcinoma when we analyzed
whole transcription data. So
we found out ST one group and ST two group
has a very good response to the immune checkpoint inhibitor.
So ST one group is very predictable.
High PD-L1 and rich transcription TME
microenvironment.
It is very predictable. But very interestingly, ST
two has very
similar
benefit from the immune checkpoint inhibitor.
But this population was not defined
any specific genetic or transcription
characteristics. So we analyzed this population very
carefully
compared with the other groups. Actually, we found out
this group has a very high MMR deficiency
signature. It is not DNA signature.
Usually MMR signature is from the DNA signature or
scarring signature. But this is from the
transcriptomal signature, and we analyzing
a paired DNA result. So actually they don't any
MMR deficiency mutation or any MMR-related DNA
change. But this population has a
transcriptional level, so MMR deficiency was
observedSo this
case is related to that issue. So 68 years
old male, adenocarcinoma never smoker, KRAS
G12A. He was treated platinum-based
chemotherapy and docetaxel, and PD-L1 zero
score. Of course, we can try the immune checkpoint inhibitor
monotherapy, but actually, usually I meet the
patient with this profiling, actually expected response rate
is less than 5%. So sometimes the patient
give up the opportunity of immune checkpoint inhibitor
because response rate is too low.
But fortunately, he was treated the immune checkpoint inhibitor
again.
So as you can see, just with atezolizumab,
red color actually tumor has
dramatically shrinked.
And this
dramatic remission is maintained
actually six years.
But we don't know why this patient is
very well responding to the immune checkpoint, just the monotherapy.
So
actually, through this, our analysis, actually this patient had a
transcriptional MMR deficiency.
Of course, it is not the official name of the category, we
just named this category from the
whole transcriptome MMR classification.
So we are moving to the resistance factor too.
So actually, our group is focusing on the
hyperprogression issue. Of course, now hyperprogression issue
not a big deal for the lung clinicians because we are
using immune checkpoint inhibitor and chemotherapy combination is
widely used. But still,
especially never smoker population, for example, EGFR TKI,
ALK TKI treated, usually second line is
the chemotherapy, platinum chemotherapy, and the third line
is docetaxel. And then usually we are using
monotherapy checkpoint inhibitor.
So that population, actually Korea and Japan,
are enriched in never smoker. So that population has a big problem.
So we should treat it with monotherapy.
Is there any risk of hyperprogression?
Because it is very harmful to the patient.
So of course, we are analyzing hyperprogression issue now.
But very important issue is we should know that
resistance biomarker, in addition to sensitive biomarker
for this special population lung
adenocarcinoma lung cancer in never smoker.
So actually, we find out again the whole transcriptome
signature. So DDR is a very interesting
biomarker. So as you can see, all population of the
500, there is no difference according to the DDR1.
And again, we are limiting just squamous carcinoma.
Paradoxically, DDR1 is highest expression
in the lung squamous carcinoma. But if we
dissect according to the DDR1 level, so lung
squamous carcinoma has no predictive value of DDR1.
But very interestingly, never smoker lung adenocarcinoma population
has the very unique separation of
PFS from the
immune checkpoint monotherapy just with the DDR level.
So DDR is of course a very important
marker for T cell infiltration. As you know, if
VCAM and ICAM expression is lower, and that
means T cell infiltration is impaired.
So this biomarker could be important for the
never smoker population.
So it is another very interesting sensitive and resistant
markers. EGFR exon 19 never smoker, TKI
and platinum chemotherapy. So actually,
we should decide this patient either toxic or
immunotherapy, or to give immunotherapy.
But PD-L is high, actually two-- I will show the two
case.
First case is pembrolizumab two years, had a very good
remission. So he's still alive four years.
And second case is the very two cycle to pembrolizumab.
But she has very
unique pattern of hyperprogression.
So actually she died just four months.
So that's why we need the resistant and sensitive
biomarker for selection of immune checkpoint inhibitor in never smoker lung
cancer. So in this case, first case is
low DDR1 expression, and second one is DDR high
expression. So it will be very important to
personalize the treatment for the never smoker lung cancer,
because actually never smoker lung cancer has a very heterogeneous
tumor microenvironment, et cetera.
So it is another example of whole genome doubling issue.
So recently, whole genome doubling is recognized as a very
important
biomarker for tumor evolution. But there is no data
regarding the immune checkpoint inhibitor response.
So we saw the result of whole genome sequencing
data. Of course, the whole genome doubling
is associated very poor
T cell infiltration and poor
lower TCR and PD-L1 expression level in the tumor.
So as you can see,
actually all population has the left side
and lung cancer in never smoker is right side.
Left side,
these data shown, whole genome doubling is another
predictive or prognostic marker for immune checkpoint inhibitor.
AndInterestingly, actually many
biomarkers in smoker is not adaptable to the never
smoker lung cancer. But this whole genome doubling is
very well adaptive to the never smoker issue.
So we are
researching why whole genome doubling is related to the resistance
to the immune checkpoint inhibitor.
Actually, we are now expanding over the
Immuno-Oncology Clinical Genomics cohort.
So if we
get more number of patients, we can see
another heterogeneity and another sense of predictive
biomarker for the never smoker lung cancer.
It is probably linked to the next
topic. So actually 2019, we found out
that LINE1/LIN2 global hypermethylation
is related to poor responses to the immune checkpoint
inhibitor. So actually, probably Dr.
Landi probably will show some very
interesting data for
LINE1/LIN2 global hypermethylation.
Of course, this feature is related to smoker
issue. So actually, I dissected this
biomarker, never smoker and smoker.
This biomarker is very unique to the smoker
from our IO accord.
Actually never smoker there is no predictive value of
this biomarker, but smoker very good predictive marker for immune
checkpoint inhibitor.
So again, we are
establishing the 30,000 genome LINE
lung cancer. Actually, as you commented, half of the patients
are never smoker lung cancer. So
increasing this number of the... Actually, we just
did the whole genome sequencing. So there is
some good collaboration and
work together for the never smoker lung cancer,
or the better approaches with immune checkpoint inhibitor.
So take home message is EGFR TKI benefit is larger
in never smoker and ALK is very similar.
And immune checkpoint inhibitor monotherapy has a very less benefit to
the lung cancer in never smoker.
But never smoker should not be regarded as exclusion
factor to immune checkpoint inhibitor.
And we should focus on both sensitive and
resistance marker for this population.
Of course, a large data set is definitely needed
for this type of reverse translational research.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you very much, Dr. Lee.
I think it is very rare case to discuss about smoking
and treatment efficacy. But due to a time
limitation, we can take two questions. Yes, please.
Hi. Thank you. I'm Sophia from City of Hope.
I wanted to ask
whether there is any distinct biomarker
profiles in
passive smokers that you identified?
And then I also have a question about whether
there is any current AI or
geospatial mapping, for
example, the
geographic
pollution, environmental pollution, and
also family genomic in Japan.
Thank you.
Yeah. Actually, first of your question
regarding. So
actually,
for that issue, so actually patient smoking is just dependent
on the patient comment or a family's comment.
So it is sometimes not reliable for the real smoking
history. So of course, Dr. Konno showed
that smoker
signature is not definite for a passive
smoker patient. But
again, APOBEC signature is the one of the patient smoker,
could be a patient smoker signature.
So actually, we also found out that APOBEC signature has
some of the passive smoking signature.
Of course, not exclusively
means passive smoking, but it is a part of a passive smoking, and
that it is a definitely predictive value for the
EGFR TKI. So patient have never smoker or patient
smoker, APOBEC signature has the worst prognosis
compared to no APOBEC signature.
Is it a partial answer to your question?
A second one is very difficult. So actually, before this
session, I discussed with some Japanese scientists.
So it is very difficult. So actually from the
Nature 2.5 paper. So actually
Korean and Taiwan had a PM 2.5 average
is around 30.
But Japan has the much lower than the Korean
and
Taiwan. Usually averaging is 10 to 15,
and UK is also averaging 10 to 15. So I don't
know why actually Japan and Korea, Taiwan has
a different
air pollution environment. But actually
increasing the never smoker lung cancer face same issue.
So actually we should work together to solve this problem.
Yes.
Okay, so next question please.
Thank you for your very nice talk. I have a clinical question.
I was wondering, what is your experience with thechemo
IO
with patients with rarer EGFR
mutations like exon 20 insertion or
even variants of--
We don't know what the function of these variants are.
Yeah. As you know, so actually, so we already have a very
good regimen, the amivantamab chemotherapy regimen.
Yeah. Definitely, so better.
Now, EGFR and bispecific antibody is the standard of care
for exon 20 insertion. Yes. So in chemotherapy has
a better approaches and better response.
Definitely, yes.
Okay.
Given that what you know now, can you
share how you select patients for chemo IO
regimen?
Yeah. It should be solved with our
cohort data. Now, actually, we usually
just give chemo IO based on just the patient's
performance data, so other parameter or tumor
burden according to the PET scan and pre-MRI, et cetera.
Yeah. But actually, near future, we should find
our very good biomarker to decide
those population. Yes. Immunocheckpoint inhibitor and combination
therapy even after EGFR TKI and
EGFR TKI failure. So actually, we have a sure choice, yes,
platinum-based chemotherapy only or chemotherapy IO. Yeah.
Actually, this type of, yes, collaboration in the global
is needed, I think. Yes. Thank you very much.
Sorry. Due to the time limitation, let's move on to
the final speaker. Thank you very much, Dr Lee.
The last speaker of this session is Dr
Maria Teresa Landi of NCI.
As you may know that she has published a very good
nature
papers discussing about how
lung adenocarcinoma never smoker develops.
So, could you please start your presentation?
Thank you. Thank you, Takashi. I'm very glad to
be able to present some of the results of the Sherlock study.
I have no
financial relationship to disclose.
So Sherlock has two major aims, to characterize the
molecular and evolutionary landscape of lung cancer in never smokers,
and to develop a prognostic classification of these tumors.
So in the interest of time, I will focus only on some of the
results from aim one, and particularly focus on the lung
adenocarcinoma. But I just want to mention that some of the
results from aim two were presented previously and can be found in
the proceeding.
Currently, we have assembled data and specimens for
almost 5,000 individuals, of whom almost 3,000 have
multi-omics data and include mostly non-smokers, but there
are also smokers, and you can see here the distributions by age,
sex, geographical region, and so on.
But we began a few years ago with a small
pilot study,
based on whole genome sequencing.
And through the analysis of copy number alterations, we
identified three subtypes that using musical
terminology we call the piano, mezzo-forte, and forte with increasing
genomic alterations.
The forte was associated with the whole genome doubling.
The mezzo-forte was enriched with the EGFR mutation and copy
number alterations. And the piano, a very
quiet genome, but had enrichment of KRAS mutations.
Actually, 76% of the KRAS
mutations was in this subtype.
I just wanted to say that this EGFR and KRAS type of
mutations will recur a lot during my talk, and I will
then explain why toward the end.
So currently, I will describe data from
1,200 individuals, of whom almost
900 are never smokers and 345 are smokers.
The first thing we analyzed was the mutational signatures, the patterns
in the cancer genome that reflect the mutational processes.
And what we saw, that the large majority were actually
associated with endogenous processes, endogenous meaning within the
organism. And I highlighted here in different colors those that
we think are associated with endogenous processes like
SBS1 and 5 for age or APOBEC or reactive
oxygen species and so on.
This was based on single base substitution, but we tested also other
type of signatures, and among the indels, we identify
one specific deletion, ID2, a deletion in a
homopolymer of T in a subgroup of tumors that
had a very aggressive behavior. In fact, the number
of these ID2 were strongly correlated with a
series of tumor proliferation markers.
And we showed that this ID2 is actually a by-product
of the activation of one of the major retrotransposon, line
one, that has the capacity to copy and paste across the genome,
creating damage on the DNA randomly.
We also looked at the identified exogenous
processes. For example, when we divided the subjects
between those with East Asian and European ancestry,
we found similar distribution but with some notable differences.
For example, in the
tumors come from Taiwan, there was this
signature, Signature 22A, associated with aristolochic
acidThat is contained in some medicinal herbs that
are used in this area of China.
We also looked at the secondhand tobacco smoking.
We found very
small increase on
mutations in the tumors from subjects that
had a strong secondhand tobacco smoking exposure.
But we found no increase of a specific
signature, but we saw a decrease on the
telomere length in those with
secondhand tobacco smoking exposure, suggesting a
potential promoter effect with the higher cell replication
rate.
When we tested the outdoor air pollution linking
satellite data of PM2.5 with the residents of
the subjects, we saw that the tumors from subjects
living in more polluted areas had higher levels of
single-base substitutions, and this association remained significant after
correction for multiple comparison.
And we saw again, the decrease of the telomere length in the subjects
with the high pollution.
This time, we did observe an increase on enrichment
of the specific signature, SBS5, the clock-like, and also
potentially linked with this higher cell replication rate.
And we also observed SBS4, the signature that is typically associated
with tobacco smoking. These were non-smokers, but from
very polluted areas. And we saw in these same tumors
an increase of the mutations in the TP53 gene.
This was based on outdoor pollution.
But we also were able to analyze the subset
of the subjects from the Shanwei, China, where
women, particularly in the past, were constantly exposed to
coal combustion using for cooking or heating, and there was a
question before in the public, so you can see that we did address
these questions. And women from this area
actually have a mortality rate of lung cancer that has been
estimated to be almost five times those of the average
in China.
And when we examined the different combustion
pollutants within the coal in population from
Shanwei in comparison to the population from Kunming,
another area of China where they did not use this type of
coal, and we saw that there was an increase of SBS,
DBS, iD, all the mutational signatures in
those in Shanwei, including the SBS4,
previously associated with tobacco smoking.
And when we compare these patterns with the PICO study
comparing smokers versus non-smokers for the same type of
carcinogens, this time in cigarette smoking, we saw a
similar increase of the different signature, but if any, the difference
between smoker and non-smoker was smaller than the difference
between Shanwei and Kunming population.
So this, again, emphasized the importance of the indoor
pollution in a population like the East Asian that had
already EGFR mutation, many of these cases.
We also wanted to explore how these molecular processes
influenced the evolution of adenocarcinoma.
If you consider here, I put some of the major signature that we
identified. And below this line are the
signature that are mostly clonal, so participating in initiation of
the tumor, and above is subclonal, so they are more involved in
the progression of the tumor.
And what we noticed in the signature associated with smoking or
coal combustion, the exogenous signature were mostly
clonal. While the
endogenous processes
really follow the entire progression. They are more clonal and subclonal.
For example, here is the famous APOBEC.
And so we wanted to study the interplay of
these exogenous and some of these endogenous signatures
in the evolution of these tumors. So we zoomed into
the smokers, so we could have the exogenous exposure and divided the
tumors between those with low and high APOBEC
endogenous. And what we saw, the
tumors with low APOBEC had an enrichment with the
KRAS mutation. And intriguingly, these tumors
had the earlier age of diagnosis, up to 10
years earlier than the subject with the high APOBEC.
The
tumor experience cell death and cell regeneration, and took a
longer time to develop.
But this association with the KRAS, with the rapid
development of the tumors, were also reflected on when we studied the
tumor latency. Here for latency, I mean
the distance in time from the estimated
progenitor cells that has all the clonal mutations accumulated
during the age of the individuals and the age of diagnosis.
The tumors that had KRAS mutation had shorter
latency, so they were more aggressive.
At five years average,
expressing a shorter latency. When
instead, the tumors harboring EGFR mutation had
more indolent type of development with over six
years in comparison to tumors without EGFR.
We saw also a longer latency in females versus males,
but this was smaller in European mostly.
But this interplay of the different driver genes was really
attracting, so we studied more in depth.
As expected, we have KRAS oncogenes are mostly in
smokers and EGFR in never smokers.
But even simply by looking at the colors, in the smokers, there is
much more heterogeneity, which is also reflected in more
heterogeneity in the pathwayWell, in
non-smokers, we saw that 84% were
actually associated with the alterations on the
RTK-RAS pathway. We saw also different distributions
of the co-occurring TP53 mutation,
very predominant in the smokers, and dominant in the
non-smokers with the RTK-RAS-RAF pathway.
But within this pathway, we observed some interesting
differences. So the co-occurring of TP53 was
higher in the presence of EGFR mutation in
comparison to the co-occurrence of TP53 with KRAS
mutation. And this is something that I will talk more about it
later. We also saw some differences
between East Asians and European.
Of course, we had EGFR more in East Asian than European,
and there was a question before about the distributions of the different mutations
across the gene. We did see an increase of the
L858R in the East Asian in comparison
to the European, with also some more spread type of
mutations in the European.
And Olivia Lee presented some of this data and can be
found in the proceeding.
We also wanted to study how the tumor evolve in terms
of what comes first in terms of driver mutations versus
copy number alterations. So using the Lucid
Platford
algorithms, we identified three
different subtypes.
The first two were dominant in lung cancer in never smokers,
and the third are mostly in smokers, but approximately
18% of the non-smokers actually follow the
trajectory of the smokers.
In the first, that we called
loss, because it was
initiated by TP53 and EGFR.
EGFR mutation here was 76%, so extremely frequent,
but was followed by copy number loss before the copy number
gain. While instead the other one had still
EGFR and TP53, a lower frequency, and it was
followed by copy number gain here, the copy number gain are in red.
The third, that was dominated by the smokers, did
not have a lot of mutations in EGFR.
As suspected, it was driven by KRAS, but also
STK11, and other, TIP1, and other, many
other single base substitutions followed, here in green, and
very low number of copy number alteration.
And these patterns was also significant after adjusting for
multiple comparison, when you could see that the tumors with the mutation in
EGFR were enriched with the
copy number alteration, and the tumors carrying mutations
in KRAS were inversely related with copy number alteration.
And we saw also similar pattern when we studied the structural
variants. Here you can see the entire panorama of all the structural
variants we identified in lung cancer.
And, of course, as expected, that there were more structural
variants in smokers than non-smokers.
But when we looked at the categories of structural variants,
we saw that the complex one, those with the multiple break points,
were actually more frequent in never smokers, while the simpler one
were in smokers. And we saw also interesting
patterns with driver mutations. The tumor-carrying mutations in
EGFR had many more structural variants than the
tumor-carrying KRAS mutation. And again, this
association was strongly significant after adjusting for many other
comparisons with the EGFR mutant tumors having many more
structural variants than those with the KRAS
mutation.
And tomorrow, there will be a presentation from Lixin Yan from the University
of Chicago, explaining many more of these details.
I invite you to go to his presentation.
Using transcriptomic data, we also
looked for prognostic prediction in this lung cancer in
never smokers. And using non-negative matrix
factorization, we were able to identify three patterns that
Dr. Hunsen presented before.
We call them as steady, proliferative, and chaotic.
Steady was enriched with markers of alveolar
cells, proliferative with the fusions, and the
chaotic with the epithelial to mesenchymal transition.
Now, these three transcriptomic groups
completely, very strongly predicted the overall survival,
even when we zoomed into stage I, or even when
this analysis only in tumors without
TP53 mutations. So we thought this
information could be useful in clinic, but to
analyze the entire transcriptomic is very challenging in normal
clinical setting. So using a series of statistical
approaches, we derived a signature of 60 genes that
we validated also in a population from Singapore, just 110
subjects, the largest we could find.
And we
found that although they did not have enough numbers with the
chaotic subtype, there was a very clear discrimination between
those with the steady and proliferative subtypes in
both overall and within stage I.
And in fact, when we used this transcriptomic data
together with the stage, we obtained the best prediction
model for lung cancer in never smokers in this population.
And we also identified some genes that
were most enriched in the proliferative and the chaotic
subtypes that could be targetable.And Wei
Zhao will present some of these results in the follow-up on spatial
transcriptomics, and invite you to see her work too.
So now, at this point, I would like to
synthesize some of these results that are presented based on molecular
processes, driver genes, evolutionary trajectories,
to propose a unifying
biological framework for lung cancer, or at
least lung adenocarcinoma in never smokers.
So we saw that EGFR is more common in never smokers, and
the mutations in the RTK RAS/RAF pathways really
dominate in the entire picture.
We also saw that the tumors with the KRAS mutation tend to
occur at early age of diagnosis and have a rapid,
shorter latency in comparison to tumors carrying
mutations in EGFR that appear to be more
indolent and require something else to progress.
For example, the TP53
co-occurring genes and mutations, which
convey genomic instability, or major
changes, like the somatic or common number
alterations of structural variants.
And actually, these entire patterns resemble what we saw in the original
pilot study, when we saw that those subtypes with the
EGFR mutation and many more copy number alterations than those enriched
with the KRAS alteration. So, as Dr.
Connors suggested in his talk, there is clearly evidence
that the tumors that carry mutation in
EGFR and tumor that carry mutation in KRAS have different evolutionary
trajectories.
Now, the question is, why is this? Is it related to
the potency of these genes, or there are
other factors? And I propose that at least one of
the contributing factors is actually the cell of origin
where these tumors arise from.
I mentioned that in the transcriptomic data, that the steady
subtypes that enrich with alveolar cells and also had
more EGFR mutations had a better prognosis, which is in
line with the indolent subtype. But when we
say alveolar cells, we have to
take into consideration that there are at least two major types, the
AT2 cells that produce the surfactant and
also have stem cell capacity, and the AT1 cells that are involved
in the oxygen exchange.
We also know that the AT2 cell, because of this stem
line capacity,
upon injury, can completely differentiate into
AT1 cell to ensure the continuation of the
oxygen exchange.
Now, we also know that potent oncogenes
like the KRAS oncogene can hijack this
functional
stem cell capacity to give rise to rapid
growing tumors, as we have seen in many lung cancer from
smokers.
But a couple of years ago,
Nick Jewell and Tushar Desai from Stanford published
results in animal model, where they showed that actually, this
could be that the AT1 cell can give rise
to tumors that have indolent features, and they have
typical histological features like lipidic, like we find in many
lung cancer in never smokers associated with GGO, ground-glass
opacity. These colleagues at
Stanford showed that this AT1 to
AT2 reprogramming is a slow process, and the
RTK RAS/RAF pathway have a very important role in this
trajectory. And this is exactly the pathway that is mostly
mutated in lung cancer in never smokers.
We were intrigued by these results and start thinking, "Would it be
possible that the tumors that have the EGFR mutations and
appear to be indolent actually arise from
AT1 cell?"
In support of this hypothesis, single-cell RNA
sequencing data shows that the AT1 cell
most frequently at a higher level express EGFR
than AT2 cell. And now, a mutation in EGFR
needs the expression of the gene in order to be functional.
So this was intriguing. And the colleagues
from Stanford also showed that this
reprogramming from AT1 to AT2 cells
experience really is epigenetic constraint that
is kept. So while the transcriptomic varies from AT1
to AT2, the
epigenetic features remain constant, at least at
the beginning of the stage of these tumors.
And so we thought, "Oh, this could be the reason for which the indolent
tumors that we see with EGFR mutation
requires, apparently, major genomic changes," probably
because they have to overcome this epigenetic constraint.
And in fact, we saw that they have many copy number alteration and complex
structural variants.
While there was this publication, another group, also from
Stanford, the Kaiser group,
showed, still in animal models, that the passage, the
transition, the differentiation between AT2 and
AT1 cells require TP53
functioning.
So one can hypothesize that you have EGFR mutation
in AT1 cell. This
started to be reprogrammed back slowly to AT2,
and then if you have an additional TP53 mutation, the
transition goes toward the AT2 cells, which can then generate a
tumor.And this could be the reason for which we see
many more co-occurrences of TP53 gene mutations
together with the EGFR in comparison to those with
the KRAS. And understanding this is important not
only for understanding the development of the tumor, but also for
therapy. For example, the tumors that
derive from 82 cells,
respond very well with the
Wnt antagonist, because the Wnt pathway promotes
tumorigenesis. But the same pathway inhibits
tumorigenesis if the tumor arises from 81 cell.
And so in order to target, for example, the Wnt signaling, one
has to know the cell of origin.
These colleagues from Stanford also identified
specific methylation patterns in these animal
models that distinguish the tumor that originated from
81 to 82 cell.
And so we contacted these collaborators and
obtained these features that defines, it is just
a CPG probe, so methylation defined in 81
versus 82
cell of origin. And we tested in
hundreds of SHERLOCK samples using Epic Array, and we
saw that the features associated with the 81 cell, but
not those associated with 82, can distinguish
the low-grade tumor from the high-grade
tumor. And the low-grade tumors are actually those that are enriched with
lepidic and acinar subtypes that were seen in
the animal models originated from 81 cell.
And Cindy Lee presented more of this data,
and I invite you to see also her data.
So currently, in closing, we are studying this
hypothesis that at least a significant proportion of EGFR
mutant lung adenocarcinoma in never smokers
arises from 81 cells. And this 81 cell
of origin, the epigenetic constraint, contribute to
this indolence of this non-smoker lung
adenocarcinoma. Of course, there could be involvement of the
tumor microenvironment, and it would be interesting to see the germline
effect on this association. But it's clearly important
also in terms of early detection, because to know
this is important, because you can imagine that the tumors evolving from
81 cells, it's much longer window of
time for early detection in comparison to the rapidly evolving
82-derived tumors.
And so finally, I want to acknowledge all my team,
colleagues from the Division of Cancer Epidemiology and Genetics,
Lixin Yang from Chicago, the Stanford group of Tushar
Desai, Nick Jewell, and others, all the participating
centers. I want to thank the Susan Wojcicki
Foundation that supported part of this study.
And I wanted to point out this QR code if you want to click,
because we are really looking for more postdocs and senior
bioinformaticians, and we'll be happy to welcome them.
And thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Teresa, for a very thoughtful and
comprehensive story.
So now paper is open for discussion or question.
Are there any questions or comment?
So I have one question. First, you showed that there
are three genomic types, piano and mezzo-forte,
and
in the later part, you show that three types of
transcriptomic phenotypes.
Yes.
Are these phenotypes linked together?
So,
we didn't do a formal analysis in this way, but the
one that EGFR enriched with the copy number, the
second one, the mezzo-forte, was actually more
present in the steady phenotype with the
enrichment with alveolar cells. So yes, there is an
association there.
I see. Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Yes, please.
I just had a question. Many countries, for example, in
India, you have a lot of pollution, air pollution, and there has been an
increasing rise of lung cancer in never smokers.
Do you think that air pollution due to
traffic and carbon monoxide, et cetera, could also
contribute to lung cancer?
Definitely. Unfortunately,
in my entire collection, I tried desperately to get some
Indian samples. I could not. But definitely,
the air pollution has a role, as I showed, indoor and outdoor
air pollution. I have to say that even when we say
pollution, it's a quite
large type of combination of possible
components. So you have pollution more
associated with combustion-related type of changes,
and those are more enriched with the known
combustion-related. They are more like fibers,
microplastic, or other type of
minerals and other type of
particles that could have divergent effects in lung
cancer in never smokers.
And I wanted to ask you that, in
non-smokers, you showed a higher
number of EGFR mutations and also KRAS
mutations. Do you see any changes in methylation patterns in
these non-smokers compared to smokers?
So,
in general, the smokers are associated with the
global hypomethylation.
Then, of course, there are specific areas of the genome that
are enriched differentially with the methylation patterns.
But in general, tobacco smoking is associated with decrease
of methylation.
And do you see a higher number of people with EGFR mutations in
non-smokers compared to smokers?
Yes. Definitely. EGFR is more frequent in non-smokers than smokers.
You see it more, because the Korean groups were mentioning that
they didn't see, but I think your group mentions that they do see differences.
Yes. There is a very important
point that you are underlying here.
There is a frequency that changes mostly because of
ancestry. So Dr. Connell
also presented that the EGFR mutations were
similar, although a little bit higher, you can say, right, Takashi,
in non-smoker than smokers. But if you compare
the East Asian and the European
ancestry, there's more in East Asian, and if you look
within the European, never smokers have more EGFR
than
KRAS, definitely.
So that's very interesting that it depends a lot on your ancestry, how actually
your mutations will develop-
Right. Yeah
... later in life, whether you're a smoker or you're a non-smoker, right?
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Dr. Terenghi-san. Thank you very much.
Oh I'm sorry. I have some closing
remarks.
And
thank you very much for joining the
JCAA-ACR joint session this year.
And, we really thank all the participants and also
very nice speakers. And, every
year
we have a joint symposium, and last year was a brain
tumor. And so,
please look forward to the next year's joint session.
And Japan Cancer Association and the ACR
usually have collaborating
conferences. One is starting in
1989, joint conference in
Hawaii. It occurs about
every three years. And, we also have
alternative joint conference, precision
medicine or organ specific conferences,
usually in Kyoto, Japan. And
next, our JCAA-ACR special joint
conference is focusing on head and neck cancers.
This is also very smoking related
cancers. So if you are interested in
this area, please come to Kyoto
this June. Okay. Thank you very much for joining.